[Music]
so
[Music]
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning it has been a busy week for the
prime minister
outlining his plan for dealing with the
pandemic over the winter an extensive
cabinet reshuffle which saw some
high-profile casualties and late last
night the announcement of a security
deal with america and australia at a
time of growing concern over china
plenty then to discuss with the defense
secretary ben wallace in just a few
minutes time but also ahead this morning
he's eating less meat and has ditched
his diesel car i'll be speaking to the
archbishop of canterbury about his
concerns around climate change and
indeed his hopes for the cop 26 summit
in glasgow that's at 20 to 10.
and how less
can really lead to more i'll be speaking
to kirsty logan townsend tonight she'll
be competing for the title miss great
britain having overcome a binge eating
disorder and losing seven stone that at
quarter tonight on this thursday the
16th of september
a new alliance
britain the united states and australia
form a pact to boost their defenses and
share nuclear submarine secrets amidst
concern about china's dominance
a new alliance britain the u.s and
australia form a pact to boost their
defenses and share nuclear submarine
secrets amid concerns over china's
dominance
meanwhile here in downing street the
ministerial shake-up continues after
overhauling his cabinet today boris
johnson will appoint junior ministers to
new roles
care home crisis a warning of
catastrophic shortages unless the
government scraps its vaccination
deadline for the sector's workers
we're losing staff who really really
care about what they do who are really
good about what they do
we're going to be employing people
simply because they're double vaccinated
irrespective
of whether actually any good at
providing care
[Applause]
the amateur astronauts the first
all-civilian crew to orbit the earth
blast off on their historic mission
and the weather fine with warm sunny
spells for most places but the rain will
reach the far west a little later
[Music]
morning all the uk has established a
security partnership with the united
states and australia
at a time of growing concern over china
the deal was revealed by boris johnson
the u.s president and the australian
prime minister late last night it will
mean sharing defence secrets and
equipping australia with a fleet of
nuclear-powered submarines
the united kingdom
australia and the united states are
creating a new trilateral defense
partnership known as orcas
with the aim of working hand in glove to
preserve security and stability in the
indo-pacific
let's bring in our asia correspondent
tom cheshire uh joining us from shanghai
morning tom i mean at least in the in
their prepared remarks neither president
biden the australian prime minister or
the british prime minister mentioned
china but let's be absolutely clear
about this china is at the heart of this
deal isn't it
yeah 100 neil um it was striking it
wasn't mentioned and in a briefing uh
senior officials from the white house
were taking pains to say this wasn't
aimed at any one country but you look at
why australia is getting this upgrade
and why this alliance is coming into
being given that the us australia and
the uk are already allies you heard from
the prime minister this is a specific
focus on the indo-pacific and that means
interoperability working a lot more
seamlessly together but crucially
that upgrade of nuclear submarines for
australia this is a technology transfer
from the us which it hasn't was done
once before and that was only for the uk
a long time ago and the reason they're
doing that why does australia need
nuclear submarines where you look around
the indo-pacific and one country has
quite a lot of nuclear submarines and
that is china now despite the fact
they're saying it wasn't targeting china
is obviously at the heart of this and
there has already been a response from
the chinese side a spokesman for the
chinese ambassador in washington said
that countries should not build
exclusionary blocks targeting or harming
the interests of third parties in
particular they should shake off their
cold war mentality and ideological
prejudice in terms of building blocks
china probably has quite a lot of
responsibility here it wasn't long ago
that australia really was hedging itself
between the us and china because it
depends on china a lot for trade and
that relationship has soured a lot
australia called for an investigation
into the origins of covert 19 which made
beijing furious it in fact put an
embargo on all sorts of australian goods
going into china which australia is
still dealing with as a result it's come
a lot closer to the us and to the uk and
the end result of that is this new
alliance they're talking about uh what
scott morrison the australian prime
minister describes it as a forever
alliance this is a generational shift
and is a really significant development
in the region we'll wait for further
reaction from beijing at its daily press
conference at 3 pm today i think it's
fair to say it won't be very happy
uh tom
many thanks indeed
i will let's speak now to the defense
secretary ben wallace mr wallace i never
know whether or not i should
congratulate someone who's held on to
their position in a reshuffle so i'll
just say it's good it's good to see you
this morning um but i wonder we will
talk obviously about the reshuffle in a
second but let's talk about this new um
deal being done between the uk the
united states and australia look you
work at main building initialisms
acronyms are nothing new to you but
orcus tell us just a little bit about it
well look it what it reflects is that
australia is one of our oldest allies
you know we fought alongside each other
the first second world war
in the korean war
they are a very deep uh and trusted
partner of both the united kingdom and
the united states and indeed form one of
the core nations of the five eyes which
also adds new zealand and canada to it
so it was a natural choice i think for
the australians that when they decided
to shift from diesel electric submarine
capability to
finding a requirement that matched their
need for a long
deep capable capability in sub-sea
warfare that they would go to that
trusted partner because you know the
secrets of nuclear propulsion are very
secret they're very
uh special and therefore uh you need to
share that with certain partners you can
trust and that was clearly what was
partly in their mind when they
approached us back in march but can we
just be clear as to part of the purpose
of this china was not explicitly
mentioned by any of the
the the head of gov either of the heads
of government or the head of state that
they were speaking yesterday but clearly
nuclear-powered submarines their ability
to remain at sea remain underwater there
is a surveillance capacity that is going
to be used and it will be directed at
least in part towards china we have to
assume well i think it will be direct to
lots of different threats i mean the
reality is that at the moment australia
has deed electric collins-class
submarines a diesel submarine is
brilliant they're very quiet but what
they do have to do is what we call snort
or snorkel to recharge their batteries
they have to put up a mast effectively
and beca and can be detected therefore
quite easily at certain periods of their
sort of cycle so while they can stay
underwater if they don't move at all for
long periods eventually they will have
to come up if they're transiting or
moving and that would make them very
very easy to detect by big powers who've
invested in that type of surveillance
a nuclear submarine can submerge for
months on end without surfacing at all
and that allows them to have longer
patrols to further afield but also to
keep any adversary getting and i think
that's also important i mean again
you you didn't explicitly mention the
chinese we can say however the chinese
are taking this as a direct slight they
are livid but interestingly you know the
french are also livid about this you
know literally one of our closest allies
they did have the contract to build the
submarines for the australians i'm just
wondering how wise it is to annoy the
french at the time that we are in
essence relying on them to police those
beaches in northern france and and try
and stop the the the flow of migrants
look this is not about us sort of you
know we didn't go fishing for these
opportunities this was a fundamental
australians took a decision they wanted
a different capability in that you can
see both the chinese and the french are
annoyed about this look the french were
contracted to deliver a diesel a
submarine i think when the australians
took a decision they wanted to switch
out of that and into nuclear
that that opened up for them different
opportunities and they clearly made that
choice and of course each country has to
make those choices in its own national
security interests and and they have
taken that decision look we we have no
intention of doing anything to
antagonize the french the french are
some of our closest military allies in
europe we are uh sizable and comparable
forces and we do things together in west
africa we are we are together we are
providing chinook squadrons to help them
in their counter-terrorism fight i get
on extremely well with my french
counterpart only recently myself and the
foreign secretary went to visit them in
paris and will continue to work we have
common interests both in the pacific and
here at home well the foreign secretary
now of course of course the justice
secretary which it gives me an
appropriate segue into to the reshuffle
action that took place yesterday before
we get into the specifics of it what was
the purpose of this reshuffle was it was
it simply to get rid of some dead wood i
think it was two things the prime
minister wanted to bring forward uh a
number of women mps who you know he is
determined to both level up not only in
the country but also in in my party's
representation around the cabinet table
and i think it's really important you
bring on talent and i think he was
determined to do that we had some
fantastic people on our back benches who
who needed a time in government and i
think that is important now you you
don't do that in a one-hour you know
like me i've served every rank in
government from the most junior all the
way through to the cabinet over time and
i think it's important they get
experience under the belt so i think
once you start doing that once you start
effectively uh
changing the pack of cards the pack of
cards inevitably needs to be re-dealt or
reshuffled
and that's what happens but you look at
some of the people that were leaving i
mean you're not telling me that gavin
williamson was sacked because he was too
competent that he was showing everyone
else and cabinet up look
the prime minister has obviously lots of
reasons why he he reshuffles cabinets
but look fundamentally a lot of my
colleagues gavin has done actually a
fantastic job for fe colleges you know i
in my constituency in preston and
lancaster we have lots of fe colleges
and you know gavin really believes in fe
colleges and i think they've often been
a cinderella part of the education
sector so you know i think it's unfair
to say that about gavin i think what
what happens to all of us and it will
happen to me because that is the nature
of the politics we're in is eventually
the prime minister says i want to make
rey for somebody else and and as a
result you move on there have been some
eyebrows raised over some of the
appointments and it does appear that
once again the prime minister is perhaps
rewarding loyalty rather than selecting
the most competent people for for the
job i mean dean doris for example i mean
with respect
what does nadine norris know about
culture media and or sport well i think
nadine doris is actually a
record-breaking uh well she's a she's a
best-selling author uh you know uh if
that isn't part of the culture well
i i couldn't even begin to write a
chapter that a book let alone but uh
took herself uh when she was an mp and
decided she was going to be an author
she's sold thousands and thousands of
books and now if that isn't part of
culture media and sport i don't know
what's great about nadine is she
produces a culture that people buy and
actually want to see rather than some of
the more crackpot
schemes we've seen being funded in the
past by taxpayers money i think one was
on a program not so long ago about uh
something about 911. and i i think you
know so she'll bring probably realism to
it but she's also from my part of the
world she's from the northwest she's a
she's a great solid and competent uh
capable minister and i think she'll be
great she also voted against gay
marriage i don't know if nadine doris
has spent much time in theater land well
look i think you know as you know
cultural municipal is a very very broad
range
of of industry it's vast uh it's not
just you know 24-hour news here we are
sitting here links all the way through
to to obviously uh in a
theatrical performances but i i think
nadine will be a great secretary of
state and and i think the other thing we
we should remember is you know secretary
of state are there to deliver the
government's agenda and along the
manifesto they're there to get their
departments uh in line to live within
their means and deliver it and and you
know dcms is a very important growing
sector and nadine would be able to
deliver that clearly you do you do not
want to badmouth any of your colleagues
i wonder if you might make an exception
dominic grab you didn't shed any tears
over him leaving the rco look dominic
has been quoted saying he's delighted to
go to the ministry of justice he you
know he is a lawyer by trade and and
what i would say is you know i i started
my sort of working career as a soldier
and there is nothing better than being
part of a department
on a subject you know a lot about that
you're part of
and that you feel you can contribute to
and i think dominic's you know all my
dealings with him in the foreign office
and and you know he has had some great
successes in the front office he he led
you know the integrated review and
helped deliver that which was bringing
together uh both international aid etc
dominic understands the law and that's
you know pretty important if you're
going to be the lord chancellor of this
country but don't don't tell me you and
your colleagues at the main building of
the ministry of defense were not annoyed
when presumably you were all pulling
all-nighters preparing to send service
men and women out to afghanistan to to
to get people out of the country whilst
he was sitting in a sign language look i
i think that's unfair look what we were
all focused on is doing a job he was
focused on doing his job and as you saw
the military deployed to afghanistan in
very very difficult circumstances we
haven't given up on that you know and
let's not forget there are in in my area
in the arap there's some 240
people uh 60 people are still there that
we are working to get out the country
over 40 have made it into third
countries with their families and we're
starting to repatriate them look it was
a big operation uh dominic and the
foreign office did some amazing things
some of their officials were out there
alongside ours and i think you know we
shouldn't reduce this to to where
someone was on the night of a friday
night i think the reality was uh it was
a challenge for the whole international
community and we delivered that i do
want to spend a good bit of time again
on er up in just a second but but
perhaps that you know liz trusts by my
reckoning is the fifth foreign secretary
since nazim zagari radcliffe was taken
into custody by the iranians what hope
is there that she will be the foreign
secretary that finally sorts that mess
out well i think your question is best
i'm afraid directed at the iranians on
that you know we have been trying at all
levels to to to
get her release and others who are also
held by the iranian government there's
been a change of government in tehran
we have tried lots lots of methods
that is ongoing we are still trying to
deliver that that will take the whole
the whole of government to deliver uh
one thing i can tell you about liz liz
liz has successfully concluded dozens
and dozens of trade deals trade deals
that many in the media said we would
never get uh she has delivered that she
has a very successful
manner about her when she's abroad and
engaging with people and i think that
success will transit from the
international trade department to the
foreign office
really well just just one last question
on the reshuffle we spoke to the
minister on the program yesterday about
it michael gove has been quoted as using
racist language specifically the term
fuzzy wuzzis and homophobic language in
a speech that he made admittedly some
years ago at the cambridge union now you
may all think this does not affect his
ability to remain in the cabinet but
isn't it about time we heard from
michael gove something of an apology for
the use of that language
i didn't get to university so uh but i
do what i read in the media university
is well obviously they do lots of uh
interesting things they have these
debates where i think that this was
after they get they get the cambridge
well after he was assured
the closest i got to cambridge i think
was a you know a visit a visit once i
mean i i
uh look i i think michael gave is one of
our most reforming
ministers he did an excellent job in
education you know my children's
education is better for his time at the
ministry of education and i think
on this story but look i don't
understand i have never known michael
gove to be shy of appearing on media
rounds he is very very good uh
formidable performer at it i'm sure you
can put those questions to him but
fundamentally i know mike or he's not a
racist he's not homophobic in any way at
all he is in fact a great reforming
minister in this government and i i'm
actually very pleased that he's gone to
this department uh because we all need
some local government uh reforms and we
need to make sure that we start
delivering on a range of issues
just in terms of the the the
repatriation of people from afghanistan
the afghan citizens resettlement scheme
what is the latest on that we appear to
be in a bit of a holding position
waiting for negotiations to take between
place between ourselves unhcr various
ngos working in the region and other
international partners well so remember
there were three schemes originally one
was british passport holders entitled
personnel
one was the arab scheme those are people
who'd effectively worked directly or
indirectly through contractors for the
british ministry defense or indeed other
parts of the british government and then
there was the leave outside the rules
which were people such as
women uh campaigners human rights
campaigners journalists lgbt community
that last group as you say have been
transferred into
this new scheme that's part of the 20
000
plus that we will be seeking to bring
here of course we have to manage some of
those people because they have to we
have to get them out of the country we
have to manage them
either with the taliban or indeed
hopefully through other third countries
uh and that's what we're in the process
of doing we have to manage it because we
don't want the third countries to shut
their borders and prevent them getting
there we have to give them some
reassurances and we have to put in place
the right processes but you know what i
can say from my scheme the rap scheme uh
we are absolutely constantly in touch
with these people the people that were
called forward or eligible uh that's
some 263 plus their families we've
talked to
nearly all of them apart from about 40
odds that we haven't been able to get in
touch with and we keep trying and we
will do everything we can to continue to
support it as i've said all the way
along our app scheme is open it will
remain open we will repatriate them from
third countries we will bring some back
some of them have turned up in australia
some of them turned up in the united
states some of them turned up closer to
afghanistan and we are bringing them
back already minister good to see you
this morning thank you very much thank
you
still to come on the program this
morning uh after i have passed i'll be
discussing the cabinet reshuffle the
former education secretary justine
greening and the former attorney general
dominic grieve
and then at quarter to eight i'll be
speaking to the health union unison
about care home staff at risk of losing
their jobs if that is they are not
vaccinated
[Music]
he's eating less meat and has ditched
his diesel car we'll be speaking to the
artificial canterbury about his concerns
about climate change and whether or not
the uk can reach that net zero target at
20 to 10.
[Music]
now a courts in indonesia is set to rule
on a citizen lawsuit demanding stricter
government controls on air pollution the
country has some of the worst pollution
levels in the world our southeast asia
correspondent siobhan robbins uh joins
us this morning to to explain a little
bit more i mean just just how bad does
it get there siobhan
well as you say at some points jakarta
has some of the worst air in the world
the dirtiest air in the world and when
this case was initially brought in 2019
by these 32 people it had actually
ranked as the worst area in the world at
that point so it is a problem which
concerns people on a daily basis that's
why they've brought this case and
essentially what they've said is that
they aren't getting the right to clean
air and that seven uh officials
including the president have been
negligent in their duties uh to ensure
that there is clean air in the city of
jakarta now um as we speak the court's
been sitting for around two hours and my
team over there are actually sending me
some of the judgments as they're coming
in and it seems like it is a partial
victory so far for those 32 people i'll
just read you what they've sent me so at
the moment this panel of three judges
have ruled that the president has to
create a stricter national air quality
standard to protect health they've said
that the environment minister is to
supervise three local governors
including the governor of jakarta which
is the capital city um in doing
cross-border pollution inventory uh the
italian affairs minister is to supervise
and monitor the jakarta government in
controlling air pollution jakarta has to
make a proper plan to control air
pollution there's also been some concern
about the level of monitoring stations
in the city apparently they're around
seven at the moment they said there need
to be at least 30. so lots of judgments
coming in which are upholding some of
those complaints by these 32 people and
to give you some more of an idea about
who these people are some of them are
from environmental backgrounds some of
them are local taxi drivers who are
concerned about the impact on their
health some of them are parents who say
that their children's health has been
affected by the bad air and they what
they want is not money they're not
looking for compensation what they're
looking for is a much stricter level of
control on this air pollution in the
city so they want emissions to be
controlled they want big emitters like
coal power
coal power stations to be controlled car
emissions to be controlled so it seems
like at the moment today as this
judgment is coming in it is a partial
victory and many of them are already
celebrating
siobhan many thanks
now let's take a quick look at the
impact of climate change on the planet
uh the top line here showing how the
uk's power is produced
beneath that you can see just how much
warmer the earth is now than back in
1880 when records began then the figure
just how long it will take us uh to
reach that increase of one and a half
degrees celsius uh seen by many as a
point of no return for the planet and
finally that large figure at the bottom
the total amount of co2 emissions in
millions of tons
and you can keep up with all the stories
affected by climate change on the daily
climate show right here live on sky news
every weekday
at half past six
but let's turn our attention now to
coronavirus and the latest figures there
at 30
597 new cases were reported in the
latest 24-hour period a further 201
people have died that brings the total
number of people who've lost their lives
within 28 days of a positive test to 134
647.
more than twenty one thousand first
doses of a covered vaccine were
administered
more than sixty one thousand people got
their second at just over forty close to
forty four point two million people are
now fully vaccinated
other news now and french military
forces say they've killed the islamist
militant leader of islamic state in the
greater sahara president macron tweeted
calling the killing another major
success in our fight against terrorist
countries in the sahel
the uk and the united arab emirates will
today announce an agreement to intensify
collaboration in trade security tech and
development it'll be launched with a
multi-billion pound uae investment in
clean energy
interesting on this the white talk of
the white house is offered to call the
rapper nicki minaj
to address her questions about covert 19
vaccines it comes after the u.s star was
accused of
spreading anti-vaxx messaging on social
media
one lucky winner has won the home owned
by mexico's most notorious gangster and
drug lord el chapo
it was the top prize in the country's
lottery drawn last night and it is the
same property where he escaped through a
rain drainage pipe in 2014 to evade the
soldiers who'd come to arrest him
now even at a time of exciting growth in
commercial space travel a rocket launch
from cape canaveral in the early hours
marked a remarkable new milestone on
boards were four civilians and no
professional astronauts what's more
it's no flying visit they'll be in space
for the next three days does it mean we
can all start to dream our us
correspondent greg marlin has been
taking a look
when you think they were about to make
space history haley arsenau and cyan
proctor looked remarkably relaxed so too
jared isaacman the billionaire who paid
spacex to make this happen and chris
cembroski the first all-civilian crew to
orbit the earth
five months of training had brought them
here non-professional astronauts ready
to blast off
[Applause]
speed inspiration four
copy
into the night sky of florida it went
without a hitch
it was a spectacular show for those
watching across a huge area witnessing
with the world a new dawn in the space
race
they will orbit for three days traveling
at 17 000 miles per hour and 360 miles
up realizing a dream for the billionaire
not with them the reason i started
spacex was to get humanity tomorrow it
is elon musk's company that's enabled a
story being documented in a netflix
series and with the aim of raising
millions for a children's cancer
hospital
these are significant times in this new
space race first richard branson
and then jeff bezos flying to the edge
of space in kraft their millions built
experts say the spacex launch is a game
changer in commercial space travel
they're going higher uh they're in
orbital
space they're they're in orbit around
the earth um they're not minutes they're
days uh where they're going to be there
they have actual
um mission objectives that they're
trying to achieve and so i think it you
know it's an order of magnitude uh
more
a challenge to be able to do an orbital
flight jared isaacman named this mission
inspiration with the hospital massacred
along for a zero gravity ride it is as
much about making a difference as making
history greg milam sky news
uh time to see how the weather is
looking and most places will be fine
with warm sunny spells today although
rain will be reaching the far west later
it will be a largely dry start with just
the odd shower and some shallow mist and
fog patches
overnight fog will soon clear to leave
most plants dry with brighter sunny
spells a few showers aren't possible but
most places will miss these and it's
going to feel pretty warm in the light
winds western ireland will be breezier
with patchy rain and drizzle thicker
clouds and outbreaks of rain will push
eastwards across ireland and northern
ireland during the afternoon
coming up after the break we'll be
discussing the reshuffle with two former
cabinet ministers who have been through
it themselves before at justin greening
dominic grieve joining us next
[Music]
[Music]
and now it's coming from both sides
and it's moving this way
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail
the people here are praying
quietly to themselves
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
[Music]
now they're trying to finish the job off
[Music]
they have no protective masks or
protective equipment at all
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in the news
every time they touch and they spray
sprayed
[Music]
this is the spray of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
to the vineyards
i can't imagine
how much plastic
is lying at the bottom of this huge lake
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
it was my vision to come and protect
with life in future
[Music]
animals like lion can enter into bomas
they kill their livestocks and this
leads to human wildlife
[Music]
welcome back boris johnson will continue
with his reshuffle this morning with
some ministerial appointments after
wielding the acts against some of his
most high-profile allies most notably of
course the former foreign secretary
dominic rapp speaking to me earlier
defense secretary ben wallace said the
aim was to promote people who'd
impressed particularly women including
the new culture secretary nadine dorris
the prime minister wanted to bring
forward a number of women mps who you
know he is determined to both level up
not only in the country but also in in
my party's representation around the
cabinet table and i think it's really
important you bring on talent well i
think nadine doris is actually a
record-breaking uh well she's a she's a
best-selling author uh you know uh if
that isn't part of the culture well
i i couldn't even begin to write a
chapter that a book let alone but yeah
well
took herself uh when she was an mp and
decided she was going to be an author
she's sold thousands and thousands of
books and now if that isn't part of
culture medium sport i don't know
i will let's head to downing street
sight of the cull over the past 12 hours
uh our political correspondent joe bike
standing by i mean joe he he would not
be drawn on it ob for obvious reasons
but clearly a couple of people were
bitted from cabinet because of concerns
over their performance most notably of
course dominic rabb and indeed gavin
williams
definitely neil he didn't want to ben
wants to not want to criticize
those colleagues but it's clear that
boris johnson wants to be seen as a
meritocratic prime minister rewarding
talent those who've been sacked or
demoted or demoted are people who have
been seen to have done badly and those
who have succeeded blizz trusts
on international trade deals and the
deems of harwie with the vaccine role
have been given more senior positions
that point that mr wallace was making
about leveling up the party is also
interesting it suggests that the push
for more diversity a more representative
cabinet yesterday may be matched today
in the junior and mid-ranking
appointments today really is about a new
talent about rising stars about cabinet
ministers of the future
good prime ministers like good bosses
are looking ahead to the future treating
this almost like chess not looking at
the next move necessarily but also a
couple of moves ahead we may be looking
at people who may have significant jobs
today the middle ranking
level and cabinet jobs in two or three
years perhaps if there is a reshuffle
before the next general election
interesting that penny mordan a former
cabinet minister who was working in the
cabinet office in a mid-ranking role was
once a leadership contender has tweeted
very early this morning at 12 minutes
past five this morning she was up early
saying that she is leaving the cabin
office not clear though whether she has
another job or whether she's leaving
government altogether i should say we
haven't seen any uh ministers coming up
the streets so far this morning but neil
the prime minister was working pretty
late last night so perhaps it'll kick
off around eight or nine o'clock
joe back to you as soon as we see
anything for now thanks very much indeed
uh well let's speak now to someone who
knows a thing or two about reshuffle
base uh joining us on the program once
again the former education secretary
justine greening ms green great to have
you on this morning um what do you make
of it you're obviously had to remove
from these things today how would you
characterize this this reshuffle by mr
johnson
i think he's made a number of key
changes to his cabinet and i think he is
trying to make sure that it's not just a
covered cabinet this is a leveling up
cabinet that can really get on with this
key agenda that boris johnson has set
himself in the country
as prime minister and i expect to see
that reflected in the appointments later
today there is a huge amount of talent
on the back benches and it does feel to
me like he's right to now really turn
the page
and bring through some of those younger
mps with fresh ideas fresh energy and
give them a chance to shine in
government
well let's uh talk about your your
former brief of course at education
nadeem sahar we you know received some
criticism over whether or not there was
going to be a vaccine passport but has
generally been viewed as a pretty safe
pair of hands and the vaccine role that
has certainly gone well
how do you think he will fail at
education it's a big job
it is a big job i i said i thought it
was the best job in government um
he has a real opportunity
now to shape the lives and the futures
of children and young people
around england and therefore i think the
skills he's shown overseeing the
vaccination program are exactly what
he's going to need to be able to get
into the department get a grip set a
very clear agenda
not only for officials but for his
junior ministerial team that's going to
be appointed today
and i hope that he'll also focus i'm
sure he will i know nadine very well
he's an extremely capable and
intelligent minister
i'm sure he'll also want to make sure
he's building strong relationships with
the teaching profession and if he's if
you like building that trust back up
with parents and teachers that i think
had very much been undermined over the
last year and a half
yeah and undermined what one presumes
because of the actions of one man no
longer in cabinet i mean gavin
williamson it it is fair to say isn't it
that his was not a particularly
successive successful tenure at dfe i
mean i know one head teacher of my
acquaintance who was literally popping
the champagne last night
well um
i think whoever had been secretary of
state over the time that we've had to
deal with covid and the pandemic would
have had an exceptionally difficult
task ahead of them but i i think even
gavin williamson would accept that there
were decisions made and mistakes made
over the last year and a half which have
very much led to the decision the prime
minister made that he just needs to have
someone with grip and vision and energy
who's going to really be able to drive
forward the education brief because at
the end of the day if you are boris
johnson and leveling up is your key
agenda then education is at the heart of
that strategy and i'm sure that nadim
zahar we will be bringing forward a
comprehensive leveling up plan
on education that is part of a bigger
plan hopefully the the prime minister
will himself be setting out we have a
leveling up white paper coming later in
the autumn and i think this is now a key
moment for the government to reset
that's what britain's doing as we try to
come out of covid although we obviously
face some more difficult months ahead
but clearly boris johnson sees this now
as a fresh period for his government
quite rightly and he wants to have the
right team in place to succeed does he
though emerge from this that this
reshuffle entirely safer than he was
before i mean dominic wrap is a very
senior figure within government held one
of the great offices of state wouldn't
it have been better not to have him
continue around the cabinet table and
simply shuffle shove him out i mean we
have seen this go wrong for prime
ministers in the past where aggrieved
kind of senior cabinet ministers who
accepted demotion come back to bite them
in the backside
well he could have taken that approach i
i suppose with gavin williamson who
apparently was briefing that he knew
where the bodies were buried i think at
the end of the day prime ministers need
to make decisions and i think for the
wider parliamentary party there is
little appetite or time
for people who've had opportunities to
serve in government serve at the highest
level in cabinet
then
turning their back if you like on that
wider team and sniping once they are on
the back benches so i think
dominic raab
now has a continued chance to serve in
government as justice secretary i'm sure
he'll make the most of that he has an
extra exceptionally important role as
deputy prime minister um and i know that
he'll want to make the most of that
justine greening great to see you this
morning thanks for being with us
thank you thank you
well let's turn our attention now to one
former attorney general dominic grief
joining us in the program very good
morning to you mr grief good morning
so go on then tell us what did you make
of the reshuffle
he undoubtedly needed to make a
reshuffle because his cabinet was not
functioning and indeed his government is
in one sense not functioning well i'm
not 100 sure that changing cabinet
figures will nev will make a significant
difference unless
the style of government which he's
delivering which tends to be completely
chaotic and that comes from the top
is changed as well that said i agree
with a lot of what justine has just said
uh there are some good promotions uh i'm
sure the thought that nadim zahari will
do a excellent job at education i'm very
sorry to see robert buckland leave
justice you described
people being removed who were
incompetent but nobody has ever
suggested robert buckland was
incompetent in any way i fear he's
simply the victim
of a reshuffle where the prime minister
wanted to make space and decided he was
dispensable but that's not on the whole
the best thing to do although he's going
to be obviously robert's going to be
replaced with dominic robb who i know
very well used to be my chief of staff
is undoubtedly highly capable and will
know a lot about the subject and he's
taking over a cinderella ministry
uh which is chronically underfunded and
has really systemic problems i wish him
luck in trying to sort that out
what though do you make of
his replacement at the foreign fund
commonwealth and development office liz
trust clearly of course she's had some
successes uh working on international
trade but there is a vast gulf isn't
there between you know sorting out trade
deals
and being in essence in control of the
diplomatic arm of the the british
government
yes i i think
it's impossible to say whether she will
be successful or not uh she's
undoubtedly been successful at trade she
was a very unsuccessful lord chancellor
and secretary of state for justice but
then i think it's probably right that it
was the wrong appointment at the time it
was made by theresa may and it's some
time ago so again i wish her a good
fortune in her work
uh the foreign office has a very
important role to play for the united
kingdom oh it was the same pre-brexit
but it certainly posed the same
post-brexit
and it needs to be done competently
and the united kingdom has is losing
friends at the moment internationally
our international status is diminishing
and she's going to have to try to turn
that round i'm afraid there again that
has more to do with the prime minister
than with her but there is a really
serious problem uh that with biden's
united states not particularly
interested in the united kingdom and
with the fact that we have antagonized
our key european partners there's a lot
of bridge building to be done
i i suspect that you will not be
desperately surprised that pretty patel
remains his home secretary i'm just
wondering whether you're particularly
pleased about that
i i find pretty patel's style of um of
government um
not attractive at all
um i have to be frank about it um i've
known for obviously years as a colleague
in parliament but the stridency of with
which she's running the home office
again seems to me to be rather
counterproductive all this business
about turning boats back in the channel
which appears to be a policy that she's
espoused
and is very pleased to promote it's
complete nonsense it's a gimmick and the
trouble with gimmicks is that if you
pursue them
they diminish your status with the key
partners with whom you're going to have
to work if you're going to prevent
illegal immigration which in this case
happens to be the french so
i can't see that those are productive
policies although they may make good
good headlines
in national newspapers
but as i say the home office is a very
challenging job and i have no reason to
wish ill towards her in carrying that
work out but it doesn't seem to me that
she's been particularly effective
it strikes me that you're suggesting
perhaps that as much as anything
as much as anything the rationale for
for the prime minister's changes to the
cabinet
due in part to loyalty to the prime
minister
as much as competence in the role
well there's certainly a bit of that
that said i've no doubt that the
ministers who've been sacked have been
loyal to the prime minister as well
so
at the end of the day the prime minister
is entitled to change his cabinet around
uh and cabinet ministers may be very
upset we've all been through this but at
the end of the day prime minister's got
to make choices the question is are
those choices going to really enhance
the capacity and capability of their
government
and in the case of boris johnson i would
quietly suggest that the major problem
is that the leadership he delivers is
extremely erratic so a lot of the
problems which exist in government
strike me as coming directly from the
top if it was less erratic then
ministers would have a better focus as
to how they get on with their jobs and
some of the problems therefore will not
be changed by or improve by simply
reshuffling people it's a question of
whether the style of government needs to
be altered from downing street
dominic grief good to see you thanks for
joining us thank you
still to come on the programme i'll be
speaking to a health union about care
home staff at risk of losing their jobs
from being unvaccinated against
coronavirus that's coming your way after
this
[Music]
now there are fears of a mass exodus of
social care staff in england if the
government doesn't abandon its no jab no
job rule care workers have to be double
vaccinated by november the 11th or risk
being banned from care homes to achieve
this
they need to have their first vaccine by
today but health unions say the rule
will cause catastrophic staff shortages
arsenal huranak has been taking a
do
look
like it
i hope so
because your hands look beautiful now
delma has been a carer for seven years
but this could be her last few weeks
because she doesn't want the covert 19
jab and no jab means no job
i'm not saying that there's no clovid
but i don't actually
trust the vaccine if i'm a 100
i'm not sure what if i want it or if i
don't want it
i'm not saying it's fake but
it's just people have reactions from the
vaccine which i've heard about we start
taking a few more of these off fear and
distrust still felt by some of the five
million people not vaccinated in england
including care workers who must be
jabbed by today and have a second
vaccine booked by mid-november anyone
not jabbed by then can no longer work in
care homes
a warning from some leaders it would
mean losing irreplaceable talent and
hiring based on a health choice rather
than ability
we're losing staff who really really
care about what they do who are really
good about what they do
we're going to be employing people
simply because they're level vaccinated
irrespective
of whether actually any good at
providing care
and the harm that can cause
is you know untold harm
out of nearly 600 members of staff 40
will have their contracts terminated
it's a divisive debate on the wards but
even those who've chosen to be
vaccinated do sympathize you think i'll
drop it before you
the lack of choice some see as unfair i
can understand the reasons why
they've made it mandatory because
obviously we're dealing with incredibly
vulnerable adults
um
but two in effect i don't agree with it
it should be everyone's option and
opinion whether or not they have it or
not
yes done they may love what they do but
sticking by a choice based on fear
beliefs or even misinformation could now
be costing them their jobs
ashnaharanag skynews milton
keynes will join now by the social care
lead at the public services union unison
gavin edwards uh gavin great to have you
on the program this morning um yesterday
on the show i spoke to uh to one care
home provider who estimated that the
shortages in terms of his workforce were
already running at 30 percent there are
there abouts i mean just how bad could
things get come november
well the care sector was already on the
brink in terms of staff shortages
before this policy came into place
because of low pay and because of other
sectors of the economy opening up and
unfortunately this policy could send
some of those care homes over the brink
we've been hearing on a daily basis
reports from our members and employers
that we deal with that sometimes they're
not able to meet safe staffing
requirements because of this short-term
impact of mandatory vaccination
combining with the longer term impacts
the government clearly needs to invest
in the care workforce that's a really
important long-term measure but in the
short term it needs to think again about
mandatory vaccination because it's
causing these staff shortages and
because it's undermining the roll out of
the vaccine
you of course gavin will speak to your
members so perhaps you can articulate a
response to a question which which many
people have which is simply this i mean
why would a care worker who is working
with clinically vulnerable older people
why would they not
take the vaccine
the reasons why people are hesitant or
yet to be persuaded about the vaccine
are many and varied they include
concerns about fertility previous
experience of health care
and also unfortunately for in some
examples because people are getting the
wrong information from the wrong sources
what the government should be doing is
making sure that those care workers are
able to have those face-to-face
conversations with people to reassure
them specifically about those concerns
and also talk to their colleagues
so that they can have those peer-to-peer
conversations instead of resources being
put into that kind of persuasion the
government's gone down the route of
forcing people to have the vaccine and
that's having this counterproductive
effect of undermining the vaccine roll
out and causing the staff shortages
sure counter-productive it may well be
but we saw what happened when covered 19
got into the care home system last year
i think the figure was roughly
30 000 excess deaths
by august by by the summertime certainly
you understand and i'm sure your members
understand that if covert is once again
seeded in these nursing homes it could
be catastrophic
look let's be clear we back the vaccine
rollout but the objective of the policy
should be to get the maximum number of
care workers vaccinated as quickly as
possible
and unfortunately by threatening people
with sac if they don't get the jab it's
hardening their concerns about the
vaccine instead of persuading them in
scotland wales and northern ireland the
devolved administrations have not gone
down the route of mandatory vaccination
and they have significantly higher
vaccination rates in their care home
sector so the government should be
putting those resources that it's using
to implement this counterproductive
policy into a focused campaign to
persuade those remaining care workers to
be vaccinated
and gavin just we've only got 10 15
seconds left do you see this ending in
legal action
that's not a route that we're looking at
specifically at the moment but of course
the government has opened up a situation
where we have thousands of employers
dealing with many thousands of care
staff and of course that's something
that can't be ruled out in in the future
um but look there's a whole range of
counterproductive unintended
consequences that come with this policy
but the government really should think
again and concentrate on persuading care
workers
all right well let's see if they if they
manage to do so um gavin edwards really
good to talk to you this morning thanks
being with us
uh we will of course return to the topic
of care homes later on the program and
indeed moving forward still a huge story
uh but for us coming back at eight
o'clock uh we'll be discussing this at
the united kingdom the united states and
australia have announced a new defense
partnership but
the french aren't happy as a trade deal
falls through we'll bring you all the
latest after this
[Music]
you